68% des entreprises de production
cinématographiques sont aujourd'hui
situés en Île-de-France une région qui
regroupe des entreprises des talents et
un savoir-faire résultat plus de la
moitié des tournages français ont lieu
en Île-de-France où ils génèrent plus de
150 000 emplois et forcément des
retombées économiques écoutez Johanna
Gallardo responsable de l'écosystème à
film par région il le fera c'est une
région très riche une des régions les
plus riches d'Europe mais c'est une
énorme activité une activité très
importante voilà on a plus de 6
milliards de PIB qui est liés à la
filière image dans l'ensemble on a 6700
entreprises qui sont basées il y a plus
de 70% de l'activité tournage qui se
passe en Île-de-France et les grands les
sièges sociaux des grands groupes
audiovisuels sont ni le franc donc c'est
c'est très important et en plus c'est
une région qui est très attractive en
termes d'images puisqu'elle a la Tour
Eiffel le château de Versailles enfin
des lieux iconiques qui sont très
utilisés dans le cinéma chaque année la
région Île-de-France à louer près de 25
millions d'euros au secteur du cinéma il
y a l'audiovis elle soutient également
en plus de 150 films mais une
quarantaine de scénaristes par an cette
année 19 films mis à l'honneur au
Festival de Cannes ont été en partie
financés par la Région des
investissements qui ont pour principal
objectif de soutenir l'emploi du secteur
donc en donnant de l'argent à des
productions pour que les films se
fassent et ben du coup on embauche des
techniciens en embauche des acteurs on
paye des prestations et des entreprises
donc voilà donc ça bénéficie à l'emploi
mais ça bénéficie aussi à son image et
notamment à l'image touristique et on
voit une série comme emilyn Paris ce qui
est un carton sur la plateforme Netflix
à tirait énormément de touristes alors
Paris et l'Île-de-France est déjà une
région très touristique mais il y a des
quartiers il y a des tours Emilie in
Paris même Lupin aussi donc ça voilà
c'est c'est productions qui intègrent
dans les décors l'Île-de-France
participe à son image enfin à
l'attractivité en termes d'image et donc
autorisant 1 € d'aide régionale génère
entre 7 et 16 euros de retombées
économique pour notre région